how do you feel about cuz I've read how
your the rest of the family feels the
soic thing is is kind of blowing up I
listen I think it's I think it's good at
the end of the day really I do yeah
absolutely because
it's listen I there's
always I I think that there is a desire
for self-improvement from everyone I
don't care who you are at any cost sure
I mean but everything comes at a price
right even if you were like oh I'm just
going to die in ex well that can lead to
all sorts
of bmia or anorexia it can be the start
of that sure I mean every listen I think
there's a pro and a con to everything
right as we pointed out earlier about
the Holocaust exactly this is very
thematic and for you know for my mom I
was not a fan of her doing it I didn't
think she needed to I think the amount
of weight that she was saying she needed
to lose I was like that doesn't seem
like oicw worthy amount of weight like
that seems like uh why didn't you just
kind of go for a walk you know twice a
day and cut out a few uh you know
desserts kind of amount of weight um but
my mom hates working out more than
anything and she struggled with her
weight for as my as long as I could
remember and it she feel she's lost a
ton of weight she looks great yeah
I think she's lost a little too much
weight and I think she'll probably tell
you the same but she uh she feels good
about herself though and I'm like okay
well that has to be that's worth
something if you're waking up in the
morning going you know what I feel great
I'm not on this she's not on it anymore
she's been off it for months but it's
like no side effects no I think she had
the kind of bug standard side effects as
like the nausea and the beginning and
things like that but uh but if you're
nauseous you feel like a I have my
theory though on oamic you ready for
this well wait we'll be back with the
theory right after this oh you're good
at this you know that we have two ads I
don't even if there isn't one we'll just
sit here they're watching this now going
we don't have another ad that's really
good that's a good tactic I'm going to
start using that on our podcast like
stop people before a story and then
slide it in yeah he's used to De
podcaster who relaunched their podcast
the whole family the Osborne I know I
did know that yeah okay so go ahead
what's your feeling on OIC you have a
theory or I have I have a theory why you
see so much bad press about it mhm go
so as we know pharmaceutical companies
pretty much run media mainstream media
at this point what is it like 70% of
commercials on TV it's pharmaceutical
companies oh oh oh
OIC she also doesn't want to have a
music career yeah but you could I could
we could listen TW there's enough
technology in this building in your
dad's building that you could I think
you could drop a banger thank you I've
I've been telling you that yeah and I
have
to support your daughter so here's the
theory we are Pharmaceuticals we are
owned we basic so when you see stuff
coming out about it and they're like oh
it's causing this it's causing that I'm
I'm sat there going huh is this like a
blood pressure company forcing out bad
you know to a smear OIC because people
are going to lose weight their heart
health is going to be better their body
you know there's all into conspiracy
theories sure but is it but he chases
ghost is it conspiracy theory when
corpor Espionage is a well-known thing
and has happened since the Industrial
Revolution